how's it going Brad as my name is Peter
mat and welcome back to some more dick
series so apparently there's an armor
that I missed so let's go check it out
god I hate to zoom it's just full of God
it's full of hate oh it's here I come on
ride up my skirt supposed to be here oh
no it's supposed to be there what did I
miss
maybe I need to go back to Firelink hi
thank you you're welcome
don't care come on girl
you're not that bad alright I restarted
my Playstation and here it is
yay I mean I look pretty hard but I
don't know which armor to wear I know
which are more the sexiest armor in the
game here we go
because you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh hi
I should mine it's awkward cuz he's in
that position too so sexy sexy sexy a
lot of belly moves oh god it looks like
I stink too alright next on their to-do
list is to figure out how the [ __ ] to
light this lantern because I'm not going
back in there without some light oh cool
pop up heads is ready
I wonder if this video will be flagged
for this holy [ __ ] alright I think we're
we after that a lot of armor and I think
we're ready to go to the day
not bad dance three hours later we are
back so do you know where the next
bonfire is no [ __ ] you oh god there's
like triggers and [ __ ] there must get
them oh god what do you do it oh god
what are you going was that worth it
parents know that did it did it did a to
do it to do
Oh God [ __ ] this place Oh God
it's a [ __ ] suicide hole shake that
ass with me come on girl stay with me
Oh God look at my [ __ ] health holy
[ __ ] dick on a stick with my freakin
a big got a bigger better look but
always ya know [ __ ]
ha ha ha he called me fat actually he
did but he'd he would have right so now
where do we go down here thank you
oh my I was so close are you sorry I'm
on my own my cereal are you cereal um my
milk oh [ __ ] I forgot to rest at the
bonfire
oh my god I'm so stupid Oh what oh no
not these atrocities Roberts that points
you [ __ ] idiot
I forgot to read Satta bonfire
yes I did yes I did yes I did
ed Gary is something my Laird will you
please stop I'm f---ing me it's pretty
gay not that there's anything wrong with
that I'm okay with you being gay I'm not
trying to be judge full but it's just
the fact that you're a dog and now I
just fell down like a [ __ ] idiot god
damn it son of a [ __ ] yeah the worst
part of this game is when you make it
even harder for yourself because you're
an idiot
have you ever seen a man with titties
before well now you have you're welcome
stop Edgar stop humping me ah damn you
perv all that son of a [ __ ] pushed me
God why do you do this tell me bye I'm
fat and I know it my tears will shake
and I show it chicken potatoes for me go
don't ya God what did I say once
oh god that's out of time I hate it went
to my yang ya can't even talk so very
bad I'm not fat just have a big arm or I
swear come on it's the truth I'm
actually skating like a model underneath
this is not fair this outfit is not
complimenting me
why can't we just go out together caring
I don't date models why don't you come
here and fight me like a titty man like
I am can we nope them yes we can yes we
can I would roll over a day Oh what is
this peasant americano Conoco my
favorite weapon in the game thank you
sir where's the bean fire waste to being
fired I know there's a ban fire Oh si si
senorita one fine friend yareta why do
you always have to hide from me
I thought we loved each other you are
really really really not welcome right
now kind of busy
you're a Black Knight aren't you alright
nuke
didn't work Plan B cry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's so dark in here and
you're black I mean that's not that
sounded weird okay now you just stop ah
[ __ ] a duck we are at the beginning of
that [ __ ] yeah
Oh what are you are you the guy that
keeps shooting me man I'm sorry but you
gotta go oh not you oh come on that's
you you have to take okay the plan is to
push him down
hey now now you're pushing me I don't
like that that's what I'm talking about
now listen carefully boys I ain't
looking for no trouble I'll just be on
my way over here and we can all go along
with our life no you bony [ __ ] your
bony [ __ ] [ __ ]
been fired
robots man fired check mines in from the
skies where am I ah ah no you no bueno
oh [ __ ] what's going on I'm panicking
but we we made it i intimidate them with
my sexiness what the [ __ ] are you are
they're tiny little Skelly's oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of them
[ __ ] Smurfs man die I guess I find
Smurf town of the undead or some [ __ ]
god damn oh god what am I doing with my
life
dying that's what I'm doing with my life
oh hi there naked man don't mind me I'm
describing your large white to titanite
chunk is this is this the boss let's
just hope it is nice I lose half my
health before the fight oh dude what ah
that is the good oh yeah here it is Bo
even his sword is full of bones what the
[ __ ] meat though my girlfriend's dog is
name is lethal weapon at risk
Oh No yeah this is great so far yeah
let's all chase the fat man yeah let's
all do that splendid
maybe if I jump on the sides I don't
takes nope look at that this is
ridiculous well this is fun much joy
that went also very very good I'm very
proud of that one oh my god I hate his
[ __ ] skeleton friends if I had
friends to you I don't will ever have
red a [ __ ] you and your skeleton friends
odd that dick hole hi man you look
pretty good I'm kind of stuck here god
damn I'm stuck in his ass or something
[ __ ] oh damn some people just have bad
breath I guess I have any stamina to
attack or anything
I thought I could dodge behind a tree
that's not a tree no king time yay-hey I
am the sexiest one that's what you
[ __ ] get ah yeah look at my teddy
shake look a metallic shake that was
surprisingly easy if you don't go into
the other rooms I thought you had to
like spin around and [ __ ]
but no that's a terrible idea all the
[ __ ] in the club say what they want
so I think I know where to go but we'll
see there should be a door that I can
open now this don't remember where or if
I can God dang contractions these days
apparently this the door takes twenty
thousand souls to open I hope work
please nope that was a [ __ ] lie oh I
need to buy a key let's go shopping so
he sounds the key oh there it is you
gotta pay the troll toll you gotta pay
the troll toll
here's your troll toll troll O'Shay it's
like wolfson scorpion wolf Oh Jeff
laughs getting cute you know me the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
[ __ ] O'Shea it's not that there you go
[ __ ] oh look at that ass
what am i doing huh I just poked dick a
slight poke is all it needs
that's what said what that's it one tiny
sword O'Shea he's pissed
why why that what
that isn't know how that has that even
passable
oh [ __ ] I'm pleased he doing
it's like a dog chasing his tail he's so
badass oh [ __ ] no okay well it looks
like a pretty straightforward boss fine
I think I think we're gonna do this oh
that's not all though he's a little
jumpy horrible Oh Oh No
let me heal or something no now you're
just being valued this baby just have to
stay away from that [ __ ] attack oh oh
come on come on yes yes yes I think we
did good thing yeah this is armor is
[ __ ] bad is making by my breast
that's all for now I hope you enjoyed
this episode maybe like we did I really
appreciate it and hit subscribe comment
today see you bredis in the next one
it's for you stay awesome love you okay
you need to be a are you saying
laughs it's kind of riding here come on
girl steak as for me